hi i'm charles fraser a second year
computational neuroscience phd student
at the dullners institute in the
netherlands and i just saw that the
channel reached 30 000 subscribers
so instead of doing a normal video about
compositional neuroscience or studying
or productivity i thought i would do
something a little bit different and
answer a lot of your questions that you
have posted under the videos as fast as
possible if some of your questions
aren't answered please put them down in
the comments below and i'll try to get
back to them as soon as possible or make
another video about it so yeah let's get
straight into it so i put the questions
on my laptop so that's why i'm looking
down sometimes so on the computational
neuroscience how to learn computational
neuroscience some eben no jar
combining all these topics which
projects should you think a beginner
should work on so um i think if you are
really beginning in computational
neuroscience i was trying to find an
open source project and try to really
start working on all the topics i
explained in this video simultaneously
so programming mathematics and then
for example you can find those projects
on kaggle.com but there are also a few
open source projects for computational
neuroscience that i will list down below
but i think it's also good if you like a
professor's work for example to just
look at their github and see if you can
contribute in that manner then by pedo
fernandez tonso he asked hey charlotte
i'm student who just finished high
school congratulations i want to major
in mathematics so i can apply it to
compositional neuroscience do you have
any advice for this
profile yeah i think that's a really
good idea i think mathematics is highly
appreciated in the field of
computational neuroscience so what i
would do is i would get a bachelor in
mathematics and in a really theoretical
field if you can because then you have a
super high leg up over other people in
computational neuroscience and i would
try to get some physics and maybe even
some biophysics in as well during your
bachelor and then in your master's i
would really specialize in a certain
field in computational neuroscience or
try to immediately enroll in a phd
maddie amoladi sorry if i mispronounced
your name have you ever been
disappointed in doing research in your
phd program then what did you do yeah
i've been disappointed by doing research
in my phd program quite a lot i think
especially at the beginning during
corona because i couldn't go to the lab
for example and the idea i had of what
it meant to be a phd student which is
like to be part of this community and
really exchange ideas with a lot of
researchers and be inspired every day
that didn't really happen because i was
sitting at home in
my room doing research all day right and
the thing i did at that point is i made
a youtube channel to connect to people
like you guys to really get inspired
that way and i think also what you meant
is probably if i've been disappointed by
results that i got a little bit actually
um but my professor is really good he
doesn't really focus on positive results
which are results which have a b value
below 0.05 right and i think that's a
really good mindset to have that it
doesn't matter if you get positive or
negative results scientists signs so the
most important is the question and not
the results right rc addiction mania so
question maybe you could address this in
a video
but what is it you find so interesting
about conversational neuroscience it's
always interesting to learn new
perspective as to why subjects is
fascinating so i studied
i studied theoretical physics before
this and i just find it really
interesting that you can apply the same
mathematics that is used there on the
brain and also i hope in the future that
we can help to predict certain brain
states such as certain psychiatric
disorders from the brain such that we
can really help people but i also find
computational neuroscience more
fundamentally interesting that we can
just make super amazing beautiful models
which are really creatively inspired i
think so yeah that's a super short
answer but i could ramble about this for
hours mud huff brush hunts r thanks for
this awesome video you're welcome i want
to know the relevance of topics like
digital signal processing and
differential equations in computational
neuroscience are they any useful thanks
yes they're very useful they're used a
lot i didn't mention them in how to
learn computational neuroscience on your
own but they're used for example in
single cell neurons so if you're
interesting single cell neural models so
if you're interested in that topic i
would definitely look it up and you also
have like causal dynamics which is a big
topic in the field so yeah they're
definitely used um okay by e don a what
kind of things do you code i'm curious
about the kind of work that you do i
called bayesian models which are these
models that allow us to capture the mean
and stencils of variation for the
population and show for different
individuals how they deviate from the
mean such that we can predict for
example psychiatric disorders that was
it really short but maybe i'll make
video about it at a certain point
explaining more in detail what i exactly
do my search in dreams
i am doing my undergrad bachelor in data
science can i do computational
neuroscience yes you can data science is
used a lot i would advise you to really
focus on the mathematics though in your
bachelor's if you can and the statistics
because usually people can learn data
science relatively easy but to really
understand the deeper mathematics and
the statistics that is quite hard so if
you can do this you really have a leg up
in other people that are in
computational neuroscience and really
can contribute to the field okay by
cyber security guy your videos are so
awesome thank you also i am from
computer science but also like quantum
physics i have a question do you think
consciousness is a quantum phenomenon so
a lot of people ask this consciousness
and quantum no i don't think so i think
consciousness is an emergent property of
the system it is in so i think you don't
necessarily need quantum mathematics to
explain consciousness but there are
people in the field that do believe this
but i'm willing to revise my opinion if
i see a paper that really solidly uses
quantum mathematics to
derive consciousness but until now i
haven't really seen this so no okay bye
guillaume benevides
great channel and content thank you do
you have free time like a balanced life
as a doctor student
um
i think the term balanced life for me is
really hard because i think a balanced
life what people imagine say you
exercise you see your friends you're
really healthy but you also have time to
study and work at the same time to get
some income and i think this is really
impossible so what i usually do is i
focus on certain months in the year on
certain areas in my life that i find
important so i'm usually really balanced
in one area of my life but the rest is a
little bit burning and i think that's
all right i think it's all right to not
be extremely balanced and to just kind
of bounce between certain points in your
life okay bye jenny i got this question
a lot what headphones do you use so i
use bose quite comfort 45 and i also
bought the sony headphones
wh-1000xm3 and if you're thinking
between those two which one to buy i
think they're almost the same so you can
choose any one of them but noise
cancelling headphones have changed my
life so if you're thinking about buying
them i would recommend it done by shivam
sharma instagram no question mark so i
got a lot if i use any other social
media i don't really use social media to
be honest i only have twitter so you can
follow me on twitter but if you want to
connect i read all the youtube comments
and and comments that i have a really
particular question i usually do try to
answer so you can connect so you can
connect in that way and otherwise just
shout at me in twitter and i will try to
reply okay bye
min
i'm sorry i cannot read vietnamese that
well i have tried pomodoro multiple
times but find interruptions between
very interesting would you mind telling
me the way you deal with this problem in
morning koenig sessions yeah so i've
mentioned pomodoros a lot because i
think it's a really useful technique
when you really have to cram something
but i don't use that i don't use
pomodoros when i'm coding because i
think coding is more like a flow state
so when i'm coding i just
try to keep on coding until i get really
tired so that's how i deal with it okay
by alexi
charlotte have you tried to work with
text in obsidian so i got a lot of
comments asking me if i tried obsidian
and i haven't because i use notion which
i mentioned in other videos and i really
love notion but if you're an obsidian
user i'm curious like if you can put
down in the comments below why obsidian
is better than notion and maybe i will
try to switch at a certain point the
next question is by bharat kumar can you
share a notion research page template
yes i want to i want to share my notion
research
template at a certain point i'll make a
video about it and look forward to that
in the next few weeks so by brendo
miranda well that was a long day was it
eight hours yeah it was eight hours
i find that doing more than six hours of
deep work is really hard would be
curious about your experience yeah so i
usually don't do
deep work for eight hours i think per
day i usually have between three and
four hours of really deep work and the
rest of the day i do small tasks that
kind of have to be done so yeah these
were the questions i selected there were
more questions that i didn't get to here
but please if you would like an answer
to them put them down below and i'll try
to get to them again and otherwise see
you next week bye